joining me is the former permanent
special representative for climate
change that's sir david king so david
good to have you with us this morning
now of course with your experience um i
guess what we're seeing right now in the
uk was predicted but it's worse than we
thought maybe
it is worse than we expected okay and
it's all coming sooner than we expected
i think we now
do have an understanding of these
extreme weather events
they're occurring of course right across
europe it's not just britain
suffering both from drought and from
extreme temperatures
and it's i believe driven by what's
happening in the arctic circle region
where ice has been
melting much more rapidly than was
predicted and now during the three polar
summer months which is right now
much of the arctic ocean is exposed to
sunlight as before it was covered with
ice so it was reflected back into space
so that heating of the arctic circle
region
is the cause of what we're looking at
the
reason
can be explained in some detail but let
me just say
we have
now got to anticipate this kind of
weather going into the future and if
anything getting worse
the the combination of a drought and the
risk of fires with the
heat wave
is is very severe
and i i would say to people
yes it's lovely to have a nice hot day
to get out in the sun
but please don't spend much time in the
sun heat stress is awful if you're in
the sun your your local temperature is
well above 35 36 degrees centigrade and
your body temperature should not exceed
37
so getting rid of that excess heat
becomes a real problem
and if you're sweating in other words
it's not your sweat isn't evaporating it
means your sweat isn't acting in the way
it should do to cool your body down you
need to be in a cool breeze in the
sunshine or you need to have a fan on
you so that you're blowing the sweat
away and as it evaporates it cools your
body down
i said david are there enough measures
being put in place uh
by governments to try and help us deal
with the heat waves that we're going to
be facing as you rightly point out for
the foreseeable future
i think what we need is a coordinated
plan
from government to manage
to adapt our societies and our position
against these challenges and no we don't
have this plan in place
it is a plan that is vitally necessary
and
it would be very very important to see
that
the the government when it gets over
this election business
and
it is frightening that we're in some
state of stasis at the moment without
actions coming through from the very top
um but the the plan needs to begin to be
put in place so that next summer
we are actually in in a state of
preparedness and there is a bullet for
the incoming government to to bite and
that is it is public services that are
needed to be improved whether it's
hospital staff health care staff
fire services all of these
have been severely underfunded over the
last decade and we need to see urgently
a refunding of our public services
well apart from an increase in funding
which of course many people will um
want and appreciate that that is
necessary what else can the government
be doing at this stage
well at this stage it's it's really a
bit too late the government needs to be
putting out warnings and i hear you
doing that very well the the fires are
the the biggest risk we're faced with
and this is uh an extreme problem of
course the other problem is that faced
with a drought we have water shortages
and we all need to now be learning to
treat water as a precious commodity so i
think the the problems are coupled
together shortage of water drought fires
and high temperatures
much more needs to be done
in order to bring us to a much more
secure place
and sir david have you hearing anything
from the current um contenders to lead
the conservative party that gives you
encouragement that they take the crisis
we're facing seriously
well frankly no
and that that is a matter of concern it
would be so important to
have the the questions asked of any
incoming prime minister what actions
will you take to reduce the impacts of
climate change and frankly there's been
no discussion of this at all which is
extremely disappointing and i would say
also extremely worrying
now
there's been talk of course of of
removing those green levees just to
describe for us um what you think that
would do they say they're going to do it
temporarily to try and ease the pain
that some households are facing but what
do you think that would do what kind of
message does it send if we start going
back on our targets to reduce our carbon
emissions okay your question implies the
answer doesn't it in the sense that
quite clearly green levees are one way
of us preparing for uh climate change we
we need to see
that for example
in the face of the current crisis
driven by the
war in in europe around ukraine
we we are seeing
energy prices rise very very rapidly now
the right reaction is not
to invest in fossil fuels to see if we
can bring the price down by putting more
fossil fuels into the marketplace that
would take far too long we've got a
crisis that's here now how do we manage
it today and the way to manage it is to
increase energy efficiency to ask people
to
really look after
their use of energy sources
air conditioning and so on we need to
see that shops do keep their doors
closed uh when they've got air
conditioning on we need to see a whole
series of measures to save energy going
forward in time and these measures are
being taken in places like italy and
france
and of course we should be doing exactly
the same
all of us across europe are faced with
the similar crises very very similar and
we need to take actions right across the
board
now those measures of course to try and
make sure that homes are better prepared
to deal not just with the heat but also
with the cold that we're facing it costs
a lot of money
do you have suggestions for where the
government can find that money because
that is obviously a big issue at this
moment
a very big issue at this moment is where
do we find the money this is
the sixth wealthiest country in the
world and we're talking about where do
we find the money now of course we have
run up a big deficit as a result of the
actions over covet 19 and i would say
the action
in the sense that we didn't get it all
right in the early phase and that's when
the disease spread very rapidly and we
had to move into the the shutdown across
the country
now that that debt is still sitting
there but
could we raise money by for example
raising the taxes on the oil companies
the oil companies or simply
increasing their profits because their
profits are measured by the price that
we pay
not by the volume of fuel that we
consume and so as the prices go up their
profits go up we certainly need to
be taxing them and taxing them heavily
but of course there's bigger bigger
issues out there what about all of the
tax havens offshore tax havens where
people are whoever who have wealth are
able to put their money and therefore
live in britain without paying tax in
britain i think these extremely wealthy
people need to be stepping up to the
mark and paying their share of the taxes
so i think i'm not an economist but it's
very clear even to me
that we have a system that doesn't
manage to keep the
poorer people the people even
quite high up on the pay scale
these people
in a decent standard of living we've got
a complete polarization betw between the
very wealthiest at the top and the very
poorest at the bottom
okay sir david king the head of the
climate crisis advisory group thanks
very much your time this morning
thank you